hallo leute
wasserglas
einkaufstasche kochtopf im deutschen
gibt es viele komposita das bedeutet man
nimmt zwei oder mehr wörter kombiniert
sie und schon hat meiner neues wort mit
einer anderen bedeutung
heute wollen wir euch mal zeigen wie man
auf diese weise ganz einfach substantive
bildet zunächst zeigen wir euch einige
komposita die sich aus zwei substantiven
zusammensetzen los geht's
der kaffee
die tasse
die kaffeetasse
[Musik]
der regen die jacke
die regenjacke
die hand
der schuh
der handschuh
das bier
das glas
das bierglas
das öl
die lampe
die öllampe
die hand
die creme
die
handcreme
das haus
die tür
die haustür
der fan
die würste die
zahnbürste es gibt auch komposita die
sich aus mehr als 2 substantiven
zusammensetzen hier ein beispiel ein
haustürschlüssel ist ein schlüssel für
die tür eines hauses
wichtig zu wissen das letzte wort in
einem kompositum ist das hauptwort die
wörter davor beschreiben das hauptwort
genauer das hauptwort bestimmt die wort
rat des komposit ums und das geschlecht
also ob wir der die oder das sagen die
zahnbürste ist feminin weil die bürste
feminin ist das geschlecht von der zahn
spielt keine rolle
der handschuh ist maskulin weil der
schuh maskulin ist nun zeigen wir euch
komposita die sich aus einem verb stamm
und einem substantiv zusammensetzen
ich koche mit einem topf
das ist der kochtopf
wir kühlen lebensmittel in einem schrank
das ist der kühlschrank
ich esse an einem tisch das ist der
esstisch übrigens wenn man das
kompositum in den plural setzt oder in
einen anderen fall wie zum beispiel den
genitiv verändert sich nur das hauptwort
zwei beispiele das hier sind zwei lampen
das ist die rückseite des bilderrahmens
jetzt zeigen wir euch komposita die aus
einem adjektiv und einem substantiv
bestehen mit dem fernglas kann ich
vieles sehen das vermisst
mick hat einen vollen bat er hat einen
vollbart
dieser wein ist rot dieser wein ist weiß
deshalb nennen wir sie rotwein und
weißwein
wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr komposita
lernen wollt dann probiert doch mal den
vokabeltrainer in unserer app sie länger
aus dort findet ihr die 6.000
wichtigsten deutschen vokabeln mit
beispiel setzen und aussprache trainings
nun zeigen wir euch noch komposita aus
einem adverb und einem substantiv mit
brauchst du
mit ist ein nichtraucher also eine
person die nicht braucht
findet das spiel von manchester united
gegen newcastle in manchester statt nein
in newcastle
das spiel findet auswärts statt nicht im
heimatstadion
es handelt sich um ein auswärtsspiel
es gibt auch komposita aus einer
präposition und einem substantiv ein
schrank der sich unter einer
arbeitsfläche befindet nennt man einen
unterschrank
wenn man neben der haupt anstellung noch
einen job ausübt nennt man diesen den
nebenjob ein
drittel aller komposita hat zwischen den
einzelnen wörtern noch einen extra
buchstaben zb an e 1 n oder ein es diese
kleinen buchstaben nennen wir fugen
elemente sie verbinden die einzelnen
wörter miteinander so dass das ganze
kompositum einfacher auszusprechen ist
das shampoo
der bund
dass hunde shampoo
die sonne
die brille
die
sonnenbrille
lesen die brille
die
lesebrille
das war unser video für heute neue
substantive im deutschen zu bilden ist
wirklich ganz einfach und theoretisch
können die wörter unendlich lang sein
das längste deutsche wort laut duden ist
übrigens auch ein kompositum ich lese es
vor linda kennzeichnungs fleisch
etikettierung überwachungsaufgaben
übertragungs gesetz
das müsst ihr euch aber nicht merken und
probiert doch mal den vokabeltrainer in
unserer app sieht länger aus dort findet
ihr viele vokabeln mit beispiel setzen
und aussprache trainings bis bald
[Musik]